[Music]
all relationships experience tensions
and sometimes that tension just has to
come out we can't argue and fight
forever at some point we have to learn
to listen it's only when someone feels
heard can we move forward and make the
relationship stronger the same is true
for a society people want to feel heard
and right now african-americans as a
community want to feel heard there is
work to be done at a societal level for
sure but that work also starts closer to
home each one of us especially white
America needs to have some uncomfortable
conversations one of the problems is
most of us don't know how to start those
conversations even if we want to have
one over the past few weeks I reached
out to my friend and colleague David
Harris to guide me and help me learn how
I can start uncomfortable and necessary
conversations here is one of them and
this is a bit of optimism
[Music]
David thank you so much for agreeing to
sit down and talk when we all heard the
news of what happened to George Floyd
and more importantly when we saw the
footage of what happened to George Floyd
I think it ignited something in this
nation that that hasn't been ignited in
many years that needed to come out and I
for one I think like many others didn't
know how to respond I struggled to find
the right words to say and even how to
start a difficult conversation and only
through difficult conversations and
through listening will we learn to
understand someone else's experience and
not only is it essential for these
difficult conversations to happen as
individuals but organizations and their
teams need to have these conversations
as well so I wanted to sit down with you
now to get your guidance for others on
how to start these conversations how to
have these conversations how were you so
good when I called you and said David I
need help
well I guess it comes from automatic
orientation more toward admitting when
you don't know something and asking
questions and I think many people are
fearful of asking questions in learning
situations the problem is is that with
this particular circumstance this was a
lifeless and life lessons invariably are
more loaded particularly something like
this because it's traded with history
and when you're dealing with a
circumstance that's sprayed with history
you're often dealing with lack of
exposure and ignorance and I don't say
ignorance to be negative I say ignorance
in the sense of just not having
awareness for whatever reason you know
there's a lot of things that I make a
lot of things that you're now simply
because we don't have the exposure so if
you don't have the exposure to something
and yet it's becomes a flashpoint then
the question should be how can I learn
about this not I'm dumb for not knowing
it how can I learn and it's interesting
people will apply this to math or
English or French or Spanish or science
but they won't apply it to basic human
sir
stance I find that very interesting
that's such a good point like I'm
ignorant of of trigonometry and I don't
feel bad for saying that right but when
you say you're ignorant of some sort of
social thing or human thing all of a
sudden it becomes pejorative for some
reason yeah and I think part of the
reason that that is the case is because
again people are afraid of judgement
they're afraid of being caught with
their pants down I don't know what to
say because I'm not aware of it right
and I think I said to you in a prior
discussion that this is very similar to
what happens if you have a close friend
and that friend experiences a death and
you've not experienced really intense
grief or loss some people are totally
thrown by that they don't know how to
interact with it they they are more at a
loss for words it's not because they
don't empathize it's not because they
don't care about the person it's because
they simply don't know what to say
well this is interesting because there's
that there's a pressure you know some
some people have said very publicly that
if you say nothing it means that you're
not a part of this and so there's this
pressure that we have to say something
yeah and I think that that comes some of
that comes from kind of a bottled up
frustration with silence right I mean
we've throughout history we've had
examples of when cultures did not speak
up against believe no trust me
Nazi Germany being one of them Larry
Kramer the gay activist said silence
equals death you know not speaking up is
not a good thing in general I would
agree just on it some kind of a moral
plane yes it is right to to speak up but
it's also important that you know what
you're speaking to and if you don't know
what you're speaking up to or against or
for it's very hard to articulate the
thing that I think really helped for you
and I to get started in our difficult
conversation is I started when I called
you up and said hello I was very it was
very blunt
there was no sugarcoating getting into
it I said David I'm struggling to find
words what to say and I need your help
and I think what that did is it created
a space that I'm not here to tell you
what I think and then get you to respond
to it I'm gonna start by saying I'm I'm
I'm stuck and that's what started our
conversation we did it as a team as well
yes we had a huddle and I started the
conversation by saying that I've gone on
this journey of trying to figure out my
feelings in the appropriate way to
express them but also that I want to
create a space for our team to say
whatever's on their heart and mind
without any judgment and I went first
and I told people everything that I've
been feeling and got very choked up and
then I stopped talking and it allowed
whoever wanted to speak to speak you
played this incredible role on our team
for us were you helped provide context
as people spoke you offered no judgment
but rather context to each thing we said
how did you learn where did you learn
not to listen where did you learn to
listen I guess is is what I'm trying to
get it I think some of this comes from
my having been the odd man out in so
many circumstances throughout my life
I'm an african-american man I was forced
into a integrated circumstance and
perhaps when it was difficult years in
US history 1968 as a you know eight or
nine year old child going to an
all-white school being torn away from my
you know from the world that was
familiar to me and having to sing course
women in that environment it was a very
racially hostile time in the United
States but my parents were very intent
on having me experience what they felt
the real world was they didn't want me
growing up in a bubble thinking that
everyone was african-american and
everyone got along they wanted me to
understand what it was to be different
and what it was to be perceived as
different very early on and I believe
that they wanted to inoculate me to
toughen me up in a way you know their
generation was that
generation of Jim Crow they tell the
story of traveling across the United
States for their honeymoon in 1949 and
having to sleep in their car as they
went from Ohio to California simply
because there were so many hotels that
would not allow black people in and if
they found one they would have to check
in late at night and they would have to
be gone before anyone else saw them in
the morning
and so flash-forward many years and it's
my world now and I you know the world is
blowing up there's a lot of rebellion
there's their the Black Panthers there's
the Black Power movement there is the
assassination of MLK there's tremendous
resistance in some white communities to
everything african-americans are asking
for and we need to remember while we're
celebrating Martin Luther King in 2020
he was not celebrated in 1968 I boys
found it very interesting that people
become lauded after they die but not in
their time quite often and that's
because we get distanced from it and we
sometimes realized that they were right
and I think people realize that a lot of
the moral tone that he used in his
discourse was absolutely correct and it
was inspirational and aspirational and
everything that we would want it to be
so when you ask me you know how did I
cultivate this ability to listen it was
from being different and I had to
understand my environment very quickly
and then add to that being a gay man
also I had to figure that out as well
you know I had to figure that out within
my circle of black friends and people
who were black and straight and I had to
figure out that with white straight
people and I had to figure out how to be
black and you know and then there were
kind of all of these overlapping
challenges and you know to tell you the
truth I would not take any of that
experience away it was difficult it
continues to be a challenge but I I
consider it to be one of the most
enriching experiences of my life because
it's allowed me to somewhat sit on the
outside of situations and to really
listen to what's being said because
sometimes your survival can depend on
yeah individuals and teams have to have
these difficult conversations for
multiple reasons one to understand as
you said to gain some empathy to gain
some understanding of how people who are
different than us are going through the
world and experienced the world I mean
even the story of your parents is
astonishing but I think many people are
afraid as you said it's like the death
in the family which is we cause
accidental harm because we're so
uncomfortable that we don't want to say
the wrong thing or we don't want to
offend that we just say nothing or we we
don't have the team conversations
because we were so we're so afraid of
getting it wrong how does how does
somebody start a conversation even if
it's wrong what happens if somebody says
something that's a trigger I'm gonna
give you a great example of this because
I I recently had an uncomfortable
conversation with a former colleague of
mine who I adore she's absolutely a
fantastic person I consider her an ally
not just in this but in a lot of things
and we're very mutually supportive of
each other and we got into this
conversation about this subject you know
I was talking about the fact that at a
company event that we were at together
you know all of the black employees got
together to have their picture take and
that there was a certain pride in doing
that but it was a very funny
circumstance because you know even
though there's a huge group of people
the black employees were still in the
minority so we all got together and we
ran around and searched for each other
to have this big picture taken in the
lobby of this big fancy hotel and you
know my friend asked me well would it be
perceived as exclusionary if the white
people did the same thing and I said to
her you would need to ask why do the
black people feel the need to take the
photo together because if you asked that
question
you would receive the answer that
forever we have been in the minority I
don't think a white person has ever had
to wonder in a white circumstance when
they walk into a room that their
legitimacy or their right to be there or
their color isn't all questioned you
move through the world just assuming
that everything's fine because you're in
the majority so it's never an issue so
when you see more people like you
that's a sign of progress actually that
there are more of you in this setting
and so you could look at this and say
that these people for the first time are
getting together to celebrate the fact
that they've all arrived together in the
same place at the same time and isn't
that wonderful and isn't that worth
memorializing in other words you needn't
take it as an insult against you you
should take it as this group celebrating
what they have accomplished together and
where they are and I think that that is
something that a lot of groups identify
with the conversations that I'm having
with my white friends there's one
glaring difference in all those
conversations which is we also include
Amy Cooper in the discussion because the
thing that I find a sort of the the
mirror that's held up to to white
America from that Amy Cooper experience
in in Central Park is that there's a
narrative in her head that if I call the
police I have this understanding this
narrative that the police will believe
me and take my side they will not
believe him and not take his side and my
problem will be solved and although not
everyone would weaponize that like she
did every white American knows that
narrative we all know that narrative and
I think that that conversation that I'm
having with my white friends is that
that we have that narrative is part of
the problem mm-hmm it's not that we like
the narrative it's not that we approve
of the narrative but we've never stood
up and said we should change that
narrative and that is a complicated
process that includes the relationship
with law enforcement and the culture of
law enforcement and how law enforcement
responds to things but that's the very
uncomfortable conversation that I've
been having with white friends that I
have not been having with black friends
well I think that's good I think it's
very important that you point out if
anyone's looking for the definition of
privilege I think Amy Cooper gave
everyone a fine example of that why do I
say that because it was grounded in an
assumption that her whiteness and her
feeling threatened
would automatically result in an outcome
because there were assumptions made
about the black man who was asking her
to obey the law that she would be
believed and he wouldn't so it was
particularly pernicious on several
levels and it required a kind of
premeditation of thought that I thought
frankly was astonishing actually
breathtaking that she would default to
that so easily and it was also telling
and it said a lot about who she was and
where she came from I also find it very
interesting that their last names were
the same because the likelihood of
tracing those lines back a few
generations might put them in the same
family mm-hmm I was also struck by her
even in that in that racist expression
that she chose to be politically correct
and say to the police there's an
african-american man who's threatening
yes you know yeah for fear is saying the
wrong thing yeah but my point is is like
I think these uncomfortable
conversations to your point they they
need to stay they need to happen
everywhere mm-hmm do you have ideas on
how people can have this conversation
with their children about what's
happening right now I think it's
important for the parents to simply say
we live in a world where differences
between people are not always honored
and recognized and this comes from a
lack of awareness about difference there
is a historical portion to this that has
to do with how one group of people has
been subjugated or terrorized for many
many decades centuries and so it's got a
historical connection and some of these
behaviors are handed down from one
generation to the next and they're never
questioned and sometimes they become
institutionalized and they result in
terrible behavior and so my hope for you
would be that were you to see something
like this you would speak up against it
yeah but my niece both her best friends
are black
and she is completely perplexed her
mother's had conversations with her
about what's happening and she is
completely perplexed she cannot
understand why there's a problem like
she can't understand why we don't see
each other just as human beings and the
conversation is fascinating this this
little girl completely does not
understand the conversation that the
world doesn't see the other people like
she does which is they're just her
friends well how old is she she's 11
she's about to turn 11 I mean this gets
into our education system as well
because I think when we are educated on
the true history of the United States we
can connect it to our present time the
sad part of it is is that liberal arts
education has long been discredited as
having little value because the belief
was that it didn't result in economic
gain right so you had to focus on the
courses that we're going to lead you to
a job not necessarily that we're going
to build your awareness of the world
around you the culture you come from the
government then that you're ruled by the
laws that are written that you have to
follow I find that very curious that we
have relegated that to a position of not
being important you know when I went to
high school I had to take civics I had
to know all of the branches of
government I had to know how many in
each one I had to know how it all
function I had to know how legislation
got passed I had to understand the
history of the country from the ground
up and then you know when I took Black
Studies because that was very
fashionable in the 70s and the reason
that that became a subject was because
American history and American literature
and American discourse wouldn't include
that in the history it was as though
slavery were a footnote to talk about
how great Abraham Lincoln was and how we
got over it and then we went from you
know Abraham Lincoln to Martin Luther
King to your grandmother and then you
and that and and that was history you
talk about this I've heard you say this
before how in February isn't Black
History Month it's American History
Month yes this is American history and
it's a part of American history and
there's no getting away that it's a part
of
in history so one must ask oneself why
one never learned those stories what
were the social mechanisms behind
keeping that he that will take you to
some of the truths that are being
exposed today no but now the very very
difficult conversation which is the very
difficult subject which is going back to
where we started which is how to have
uncomfortable conversations and how to
listen and how not to be triggered but
how to create safe space which is those
safe spaces in those same conversations
those same difficulties now need to
happen within police forces it starts by
holding up a mirror that white America
needs to look at itself and the policing
organizations need to have those
conversations themselves internally and
how does black America white America and
police America have a conversation about
the way forward that is an unbelievably
uncomfortable conversation that has to
happen well you know and then these
conversations are not unique to us there
are models for this I think South Africa
got into these discussions I think
Germany got into these discussions you
know I found Germany's need to atone for
its Nazi past particularly interesting
they felt a need to make a public
recognition of the fact that this was a
terrible event in history that scarred
them and egregiously wounded many
survivors and killed millions of others
their willingness to acknowledge that
publicly and to make it part of how they
think about their institutions is I
think a tremendous example to the world
and it's too bad that you know I think
we in our arrogance often do not want to
admit that we have done things wrong
that there are things to be atoned for
and that there are generations that have
been damaged as a result of that it goes
right back it's the strength and
vulnerability I mean and that that these
uncomfortable things are part of our
history yes I went to the German History
Museum in Berlin and Germany's history
is a lot longer than America's history
oh yeah and yet I was astonished by how
much of that German History Museum was
taken up just with world war two yes it
was astonishing yeah it wasn't just one
room like here was World War two yeah it
was room upon room upon room upon room
hall upon hall that this is a blight on
our history and the only way that we can
build a more positive Society is if we
own it it's part of our history right we
have to learn from it and so when
African Americans say that there is a
culture of privilege around white
culture it begins by not recognizing the
history and I'm not talking about
slavery yeah everybody kind of lines a
little bit about slavery but no one
really discusses what happened in the
twentieth century or the really this was
a defining moment between reconstruction
and civil rights that is the moment
because I could run a parallel with
Italian Americans Irish Americans
everybody else that came here at the
turn of the 20th century that were able
to carve out and build wealth that did
not happen with African Americans and it
and it did not happen because a lot of
wealth was systematically stolen and
then you know African Americans became
like a tool between the two political
parties which you know played us to
their own ends and I think there needs
to be a recognition of that fact because
a lot of this racism and a lot of these
tensions have their roots in economic
disenfranchisement and until we go back
and we look at that history we
understand the way that that occurred
and the impact that that has had we will
never be able to course-correct
so how do we move forward David well I
think it begins with historical
recognition I think we really do to
grapple with our history so we have to
look back before we can go forward I
think you look back to provide context
for present discussions not just to look
back and say you looked it's to provide
the context for understanding of present
times and how that informs our future
that's worth repeating which
is looking back reading a book watching
a documentary understanding the history
is not just to check a box and say I did
it
but it's to it's to actually gain an
understanding of how people feel or
what's happening now yeah and it's also
to place yourself in the continuum
you're not just sitting outside watching
it you're part of your part of the act
of the unfolding of history and so you
have to be able to see yourself as part
of the stream the thing the thing that
I'm taking away from from this this
repeating pattern that asking for help
admitting vulnerability admitting
mistakes you know as a society to admit
the blights and our own history but even
as individuals if we say something that
does trigger something it's okay if that
happens if is immediately if we
recognize that it has happened and say
I'm sorry and to understand why it was a
trigger and that the through line and
this whole discussion that you and I
have had is about admitting that we're
human and and the desire to move forward
it's about admitting mistakes and the
desire to fix those mistakes it's about
understanding context and the desire to
appreciate the experiences that another
human being has especially people who
are different in all its forms and and
the courage and this is what it you know
to be the leaders we wish we had the
courage to be the first one to say I'm
struggling and I need help is the way to
start a conversation if I was to departs
them and I'm sure there are a lot of
companies out there that have white
leadership CEOs presidents and they have
a substantial number of black employees
and if you're at a loss for knowing what
to say
get into a room of people of black
people and just say I want your input
and there's a lot I don't know I need to
understand this from your point of view
and I'm doing this because I'd like to
be part of the solution not perpetuate
the problem so I'm just gonna sit here
and I want an honest undressing of the
leadership of my company when it comes
to this because I've not
to think about that and I realize that
that is something that perhaps I should
have done but I'm now seeing that I
didn't so I was just in the interest of
building a culture for everyone that
works and because these are such
hot-button topics I would love to know
your thoughts
now bad is true vulnerability because
the leaders would have to be willing to
accept what was said but also the
employees would have to have the courage
to say something to someone who could
fire them David that is a perfect way to
end the podcast but the way I went into
the saying and that is a perfect
beginning yes that is a perfect
beginning thanks so much
you're welcome thanks so much for having
me thank you for listening
and if you'd like more bits of optimism
please subscribe wherever you listen to
podcasts I hope you'll join me next time
take care of yourselves and take care of
each other
[Music]